smartphones haben in den letzten acht
jahren alles verändert alleine 2013
wurden mehr smartphones verkauft als
computer laptops und server zusammen in
den letzten 33 jahren seit 1975 die
mobilbranche ist die am schnellsten
wachsende branche in der geschichte der
menschheit und es heute über 300
milliarden dollar wert smartphones haben
in den letzten jahren unsere kultur
verändert viele von uns im teilweise mit
dem smartphone aufgewachsen und über die
hälfte der zuschauer schaut dieses video
jetzt gerade auf ihrem smartphone also
stellt sich natürlich die frage wie
entwickeln sich smartphones in der
zukunft weiter
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
what's on seit januar 2014 gibt es
erstmals mehr mobile internetnutzer als
desktop internetnutzer in vielen
entwicklungsländern ist es sogar
inzwischen schon vollkommen unüblich
überhaupt noch etwas anderes als das
smartphone zum surfen zu benutzen
die einzige andere branche mit der wir
die größe des smartphone-marktes
vergleichen könnten wäre der
computermarkt trotz des riesigen
einfluss von computern in den letzten 30
jahren wuchs die mobile industrie
durchschnittlich viermal schneller als
der computer zu seinen besten zeiten
gerade die jüngere generation ist von
diesem trend extrem stark betroffen
wir haben unser smartphone zu 91 prozent
derzeit bei uns und es ist inzwischen
vollkommen normal sich per smartphone zu
verabreden diskussionen von google zu
beenden oder das smartphone als
navigationsgerät zu benutzen
bei diesem ungeheuren einfluss den
smartphones auf uns in so kurzer zeit
gehabt haben ist der blick nach vorne
natürlich besonders interessant wie
sehen die smartphones der zukunft aus
welche trends gibt es und wie abhängig
werden wir von ihnen seien der erste
große trend der bereits in der
entwicklung ist ist das modulare
smartphone
die idee dahinter ist dass jede
komponente eines smartphones
austauschbar sein sollte
das zieht viele vorteile mit sich zum
einen lässt sich das smartphone leichter
personalisieren
heutzutage muss man mit den smartphones
auskommen die auf den markt geworfen
werden
klar das sind eine ganze menge aber alle
haben mehr oder weniger die gleichen
features wege ist nicht genial wenn man
sein eigenes smartphone auch auf seine
eigenen bedürfnisse anpassen könnte
menschen die zum beispiel viele reisen
nehmen natürlich lieber zwei batterien
wird anstatt nur ein hobby fotografen
legen mehr wert auf eine gute kamera als
auch schnelle rechenleistung und viele
module können wir uns noch gar nicht
vorstellen
ähnlich wie beim ersten app store wird
das entwickeln dieser module für jeden
möglich seien und es dadurch entsteht
die so unglaublich große vielfalt an
möglichkeiten die eine einzelne firma
niemals hinbekommen könnte super finde
ich übrigens auch den gegentrend zur
wegwerfgesellschaft wenn der bildschirm
bricht muss man nicht direkt das ganze
smartphone wegwerfen
das spart zum einen geld um es vor allem
viel umweltfreundlicher
genauso verhält es sich mit prozessoren
anstatt jedes jahr ein neues smartphone
zu kaufen
so langsam geworden ist scheint es doch
den prozessor zu updaten oder nicht
teile wie die kamera oder die batterie
zu uns ja noch einwandfrei und denkt
erst mal daran wie cool es wäre module
mit seinen freunden oder der familie zu
teilen
teure anschaffungen würden sich dann
direkt viel mehr lohnen die idee des
modularen smartphones würden ganz schlag
von google gepusht project ära heißt das
smartphone im moment und soll noch
dieses jahr in puerto rico einen
testlauf durchführen
klar stimmt ist dass gerade firmen wie
zum beispiel apple eher wenig interesse
daran haben werden dass ihre kunden eben
nicht mehr jedes jahr neue smartphones
kaufen
aber wenn sich der markt und die wünsche
der kunden verändern dann muss sich
sogar apple irgendwann mal beugen bevor
die ganzen kunden zu android überlaufen
ach ja einst noch bevor wieder irgendein
schlaumeier von euch schreibt dass alle
teile auf dem boden verteilt werden
sobald man das handy fallen lässt die
einzelnen module werden durch relativ
starke hybrid magnete an ort und stelle
gehalten
diese verbrauchen übrigens nur strom
wenn sie den zustand zwischen magnetisch
und nicht magnetisch wechseln und das
muss man vorher einstellen
also bleiben die module da wo sie
hingehören auch wenn das smartphone
runterfällt
übrigens gab es gerade erst vor kurzem
eine ziemlich erfolgreiche kickstarter
kampagne
hier wurde eine smartphone höhe
vorgestellt die man ähnlich wie project
m mit unterschiedlichen modulen
bestücken kann
die macher haben fast 280.000 dollar
erhalten und stellen die hülle für
iphones und samsung galaxy handys her
aber jetzt erst mal genug von modularen
smartphones was erwartet uns noch in den
nächsten jahren
ubuntu hat es bereits vorgemacht ist
aber leider gescheitert weil der markt
noch nicht bereit war das smartphone
ersetzt den computer die computerchips
eines heutigen smartphones haben bereits
jetzt die ungefähre rechenleistung eines
computers aus dem jahre 2009
nach dem mischen gesetz wird es nicht
mehr lange dauern bis wir die
rechenleistung eines heutigen high end
computers mit uns in der tasche
spazieren fühlen können
schon heute ist es ohne weiteres möglich
mit bildschirm und tastatur einfache
office aufgaben auf dem smartphone zu
erledigen und mit ein paar
software-upgrades könnte es gut sein
dass man bald zuhause auf der arbeit und
unterwegs immer das gleiche gerät
verwendet das könnte ziemlich vieles
erleichtern wenn man die idee weiter
denkt könnten bald überall nur noch
bildschirme herum stehen die sich
drahtlos mit dem smartphone in der
tasche verbinden
das würde vor allem die bedienung des
smartphones ziemlich stark vereinfachen
allerdings wäre damit das smartphone
noch zentraler und noch wichtiger für
unseren alltag als es heute schon ist
wir wären sogar beruflich direkt von
unserem smartphone abhängig in den
letzten paar monaten haben apple und
google stark das bezahlen per nfc
promotet man hält einfach nur das handy
an die kasse bestätigt gelegentlich per
fingerabdruck die identität und schon
hat man bezahlt wieso auch nicht wenn
man das smartphone durchschnittlich
häufiger dabei hat als das portemonnaie
die gesellschaft der zukunft ist
bargeldlos und apropos portemonnaie
ausweis führerschein und visitenkarten
all das kann schneller und einfacher per
smartphone weitergegeben werden als per
hand das handy ersetzt die brieftasche
wobei ich denke dass es gerade bei der
ausweiskontrolle noch etwas dauern kann
bis sich die gesetze da anpassen
zusammengefasst das smartphone wird in
den nächsten jahren noch zentraler und
noch wichtiger für unser leben erst
jetzt schritt für schritt viele dinge
des alltags vom computer bis zum
portemonnaie und es wird persönlicher
mit modulen kann ich mein smartphone an
meine individuellen bedürfnisse anpassen
was meint ihr wie sehen die smartphones
der zukunft aus und wie werden wir sie
benutzen
ich bin sehr gespannt auf eure antworten
schreibt sie auf jeden fall unten in die
kommentare
als tipp habe ich heute für euch das
hörbuch der circle eine internationale
firma wird mit einem sozialen netzwerk
mich die ja als jeder staat auf der welt
ein sehr spannendes buch und das könnt
ihr bei audible als kostenloses hörbuch
bekommen wenn ihr euch einen probe
account erstellt dazu einfach den ersten
link unten in der video beschreibung
anklicken
ansonsten findet ihr hier noch meine
beiden letzten videos von nordson
ansonsten vielen dank fürs zuschauen
wenn euch das video gefallen haben
könnte so gerne mit einem seil nach oben
bewerten und bis nächste woche